my local MP is also the leader of the
local Council and I'm kind of in two
minds about it because on the one hand I
think it can lead to some joint up
thinking between national government and
local government
but they are two full-time jobs and I
just wonder can one person really do
them both well that's interesting Bob
costler you ran a big city council for
quite a long time which indeed produced
a cabinet minister David blunkett and of
course these are now quite big jobs what
do you think I think it's a legitimate
question to ask and I think the test of
any second job or even third job in some
of the cases we've seen is to what
extent are they still realistically able
to do the job that you would expect of
your MP it's not the fact that they do a
second job it's can the two
realistically go together and you're
quite right the job of being a leader of
a council is a very demanding job I
can't say it's impossible but you're
right to say can the two jobs be done
together and that's the sort of thing
that the electorate in in that MPS area
ought to be asking them James have we
learned anything this week that will
would throw light on Connor's question
are all these jobs doable I I think I
think Collins question is brilliant
because in some ways you might say look
look at the experience we've had over
the last few years the relationship
between Westminster government and local
government has felt much too separate
you might say actually Connor there's a
real Advantage for having someone who
can see what's happening nationally and
see what's happening close to home but I
do think you put your finger on the
central question around
second jobs which is around divided
loyalties or as Heather put it conflicts
of interest that can you do the job that
you're being asked to do but is there
any risk that you're being taught in two
directions at once and I think that
there are there's a separate issue which
is about the amount of money MPS earn
you know I think Henry's got a point
you'd love to have a system where you
really feel as though MPS people are
making the law and influencing the way
in which government is run are really
focused primarily if not solely on
what's happening in Westminster
Parliament and their constituencies how
much are they being distracted how much
are they seeking worker elsewhere I
think that's a real tension